for nearly 25 years al roker has been
giving millions of viewers their daily
weather report
but now al has a personal forecast to
share his battle with prostate cancer
it's a good news bad news kind of thing
and good news is we caught it early
not great news is that it's a little
aggressive so i'm going to be
taking some time off to take care of
this roker who broke the news this
morning on the today show will be
undergoing surgery next week to have his
prostate removed
i don't want to say it's a nothing kind
of surgery but
it is not something that people are
going to be extremely worried about
because the success rate is so high
the cancer was detected during routine
blood work and confirmed by a biopsy in
late september
dr ian smith from the doctors is
optimistic
hearing from him that they felt like
they got it early that's a very very
encouraging sign
the 66 year old anchor says he hopes to
be back at work in about two weeks
recovery time is very short compared to
the old days
well-wishers are pouring in for the
father of three hoda kotb who battled
cancer herself posted this photo of al
holding her daughter
writing you've got this and al's wife
abc news correspondent deborah roberts
posted this
image and thanked fans for their prayers
what a night deborah's been reporting on
the election from wisconsin this week
and roker says she's his fiercest
advocate as he prepares for surgery
he also hasn't lost his sense of humor
if that's
what it takes to get 20 20 out then
let's just get it out of the way
boom let's just finish it off
i'm ready how about you
[Music]